-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
#BestPrankEver tweets
from you guys.
The first one's
from @BaseballJedi.
She said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-[ New York accent ]
We're missing the third one.
Number 3's somewhere
around here.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry about it, alright?
Have some...
-Little bacon must've fell
off a truck.
-Never saw no pig, alright
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @mc-arthur123.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Always a good one.
-This one's from @Gimsolittle.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @davidbastable
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's not really a prank.
It's not really a prank,
-That's more like you need help.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, man,
guess what I'm doing."
-I think I saw this
on "Dateline," yeah, like.
"Then, he got a fork."
-"It was a human head."
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @mojibou.
-Aww.
-Hi, mojibou.
-Love mojibou.
[ Laughter ]
-She says...
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's a good one, man.
That's one I could totally do,
yeah. That's a good one.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Sweet-Shoop
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on, that's good.
-I think that's cute.
-Yeah. I like that.
-Nobody gets hurt.
-I know.
This one's from @KasiaEmerald.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's cute.
-She's the one who put
the fork in all the stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
This one's from @baconluv87.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-They're one of the
three-pig ones.
-I love bacon, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. "There were at least
87 pigs in high school."
[ Laughter ]
-And this person ate --
-baconluv87.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-That's cruel!
That's cruel!
-A piece of cloth?
-Piece of cloth.
[ Laughter ]
He had pillowcases on them
I don't know.
-Gingham?
-I don't know.
-Corduroy?
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Oilsearcher2.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good one.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Bernie's driving the car!
Hey, Bernie!
Anh-anh!
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @dldnh.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, "Very popular today,
ooh!"
-Get a little message.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, hello."
-"Hello."
-[ Posh accent] Oh, hello.
This must be
a very important call.
-[ Posh accent ] You don't say
[ Laughter ]
-Hello.
-Yes.
-You don't say.
[ Laughter ]
You don't say.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You don't say.
-Oh, my.
[ Laughter ]
Who was it?
-He didn't say.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's an old one, but I had
to do it, yeah, yeah, yeah
-Oldie, but a goldie.
-An oldie, but a goody.
-Sitting right there.
-Yeah, I know. This last one's
from @5-SecondsOfAmy.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
That's one to do right there
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
Now, I thought I'd share som
of my favorite #IOnceOverheard
tweets from you guys.
Here we go. This first tweet i
from@rosenswaaag.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
rosenswaaag.
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Both imitating
PA feedback whining ]
[ Baritone ]
Sorry.
If anybody needs me, I'll be
passed out
in the teacher's lounge.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, ooh!
I'm not wearing any pants.
[ Laughter ]
Not that you can see, at least
This one's from @ReggieGames
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That sounds like a bad day
-That's not a good day.
-Not a good day.
-No matter where that goes
-We got a lot of
overheard in the bathroom stuff.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty --
[ Laughter ]
-Both: "Please, not now."
-[ Clap ]
[ Laughing ] What?
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @KarlaCavaleri.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause, and awws ]
-That's cute.
-That's really cute.
Four years old.
-His name's not Jeremiah.
-He is not, no.
[ Laughter ]
-"Please, not now."
-This one's from @basedlindz--
lizzy. basedlizzy?
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Marco!"
-"Polo!"
-"Stop it!"
"Marco!"
-"Polo!"
-"Stop it!"
"Marco!"
-All: "Polo!"
-"I can't find him anywhere!
[ Laughter ]
That's fantastic,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's from @SJenn23231.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Boom!
[ Applause ]
-[ Southern accent ] "Fittin
this pizza in my mouth!"
-"I practice fitness."
-"Please, not now."
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, lactose intolerant!"
-[ Clap ]
-"Oh, please, not now."
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, "please, now."
I'd rather now
than somewhere else.
-Now's the best possible tim
-This is the best possible tim
-it could happen.
-for anything to go --
-You're alone,
four metal walls.
-You're in four walls,
no one's seeing you, yeah.
-A shoe that goes
somewhere else.
[ Laughter ]
That's the best possible place
for anything to happen.
-I know.
-No. "Please, not now."
-This is @ehammond97.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Southern accent ]
Well, he's giving the paw
with his right hand.
If he shakes with his righ
hand, must be a righty.
-[ Southern accent ]
I don't know.
They might be ambidextrous
but I don't think
they have hands, to begin with
but, you know.
-Well, if he scratches himself
-Right.
-with his left leg...
-Sure.
Okay, wait, let me --
Left leg scratching, yeah.
-Does that mean he's
left-handed?
-Well, you know what?
Maybe you're right.
-Which one does he wear
his watch on?
-He wears his watch
on his right hand.
[ Laughter ]
[ Band playing country tune
This one's from @jeff-hofmann.
-Jeff.
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Should I can an ambulance
I don't know what that means."
-What is...?
-Number 3?
-[ Laughs ]
-"Please, not now."
-"Not now."
[ Laughter ]
-"Please, not know."
That one, yeah.
"Please, not know.
I don't know what that means."
This last one's
from @MisterMidas.
He says...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
#WeddingFail
responses from you guys.
Gosh, there are so many
to choose from.
Oh, this is good.
This is from @ashjoy8.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Baritone ]
Let it go, Carol.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @JoplinCityMgr
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Oh, my God!"
-[ Cawing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Continues cawing ]
-Bkkh!
-Pbbt!
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates fart ]
-This one is
from @trisbmockingjay.
She says..
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Baritone ]
Get him outta here.
[ Applause ]
[ Slurred ] "Tie fight!"
Get him outta here.
[ Laughter ]
Someone say, "Real fight!"
This one's from @jcbyng.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, this is cute.
He says...
[ Awws, laughter, and applause ]
-That's a win!
-[ Baritone ] No!
-What?
-That's not what he's supposed
to do at my wedding.
Get him out!
-Out!
-Get him out with the tie fight.
-You'll never work
in this town again.
-Put him out in the cold
with the tie fight man.
[ Laughter ]
"Bear!"
-Tie!
[ Laughter ]
-"Bear fight!"
-Both: "Tie fight!"
♪♪♪♪
Mai Tai. ["My tie"]
-This one's from @604Cor.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Southern accent ]
You just might be a redneck.
[ Applause ]
That's what you get
when you invite Kid Rock
to your wedding.
-Yeah.
Might happen.
-You got to know that,
as part of the thing.
-Don't do it,
unless you want that to happen
-He's a fun dude.
This one's from @EvanTheDeejay
He says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
I love that we can't affor
"Beat It,"
so that was the fake
Michael Jackson "Beat It."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You know, you got to know
when to hold 'em.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ They told him don't you!
-♪♪ Smack it! ♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Just smack it.
-Just...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ They told him, you can co
around, if you want ♪♪
♪♪ Like I don't wanna see yo
but you could come over ♪♪
♪♪ But get out of the way 'cau
you're gonna get smacked ♪
♪♪ So smack it ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Clattering ]
-You broke your
brand-new guitar!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪♪ Just smack it! ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Clattering ]
-Oh, he's going fishing.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheering ]
[ Clattering ]
-No one's ever fished
for their guitar.
-Not even Jimi Hendrix.
-No.
-He tried to do it.
I've seen it.
He couldn't do it.
-Couldn't do it.
It's very hard to fish.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-This one is from @jaydlangley
He says...
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
"Congurtulations!
Just marred."
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-There was a bear coming
down the aisle, yeah.
That's what happened.
-"Just mauled."
[ Laughter ]
Bear!
This one is
from @radford-karalyn.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No.
Wait."
-"No.
Don't.
Just cool it."
This last one comes
with a picture attached.
-Okay.
-It's from @Chase-Rich.
He says...
Take a look.
-Oh! There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...